I grew up white secular and middle-class
in 1950s America that meant watching
fireworks on the fourth of July
trick-or-treating on Halloween and
putting presents under a tree at
Christmas but by the time those
traditions got to me
they were hollow commercial enterprises
which just left me feeling empty so from
a relatively young age I found myself
looking to fill an existential hole to
connect with something bigger than
myself there hadn't been a bar mitzvah
in my family in over a century so I
thought I'd take a shot at that only to
be devastated when my wanted counter
with the rabbi he really tall godlike
figure was flowing white hair consisted
of him asking me for my middle name
so he could fill out a form yep that was
it so I got the fountain pen but I
didn't get the sense of belonging and
confidence I was searching for many
years later I couldn't bear the thought
of my son turning 13 without some kind
of rite of passage so I came up with the
idea of a 13th birthday trip and I
offered to take Murphy anywhere in the
world that had meaning for him a budding
young naturalist who loved Turtles
he immediately settled on the Galapagos
and when my daughter Katy turned 13 she
and I spent two weeks at the bottom of
the Grand Canyon where Katy learned for
the first time that she was powerful and
brave since then my partner Ashton and
lots of our friends and relatives have
taken their kids on 13th birthday trips
with everyone finding it transformative
for both the child and the parent I
wasn't brought up saying grace but for
the last 20 years we've been holding
hands before every meal it's a beautiful
bit of shared silence that brings us all
together in the moment
Ashton tells everyone to pass the
squeeze while she assures them it's not
religious
so recently when my family asked me if I
could please do something with the more
than 250 boxes of stuff that I've
collected over a lifetime my ritual
making impulse kicked in I started
wondering if I could go further than
simple death cleaning death cleaning is
the Swedish term for clearing out your
closets your basement and your attic
before you die
so your kids don't have to do it later I
pictured my children opening a box after
box and wondering why I kept any of that
stuff and then I imagined them looking
at a specific picture of me with a
beautiful young woman and asking who on
earth is that was dad and and that was
the aha moment
it wasn't the things I had saved that
were important it was the stories that
went with them that gave them meaning
could using the objects to tell the
stories be the seed of a new ritual a
rite of passage not for a 13 year old
but for someone much further down the
road so I started experimenting
I got a few dozen things out of the
boxes I put them out in the room and I
invited people to come in and ask me
about anything that they found
interesting the results were terrific a
good story became a launching pad for a
much deeper discussion in which my
visitors made meaningful connections to
their own lives
Darius asked me about a Leonard Peltier
t-shirt that I'd worn a lot in the 80s
that sadly is still relevant today our
conversation moved quickly from a large
number of political prisoners in
American jails to Darius wondering about
the legacy of the black liberation
movement of the 60s and how his life
might be different if he'd come of age
then instead of 30 odd years later at
the end of our conversation
Darius asked me if he could have the
t-shirt and give
get to him fell just about perfect as
these conversations established common
ground especially across generations I
realized I was opening a space for
people to talk about things that really
mattered to them and I started seeing
myself with a renewed sense of purpose
not as the old guy on the way out but as
someone with a role to play going
forward when I was growing up life ended
for most people in their 70s people are
living far longer now and for the first
time in human history
it's common for four generations to be
living side by side I'm 71 and with a
bit of luck I've got 20 or 30 more years
ahead of me giving away my stuff now and
sharing it with friends family and I
hope strangers too seems like the
perfect way to enter this next stage of
my life turns out to be just what I was
looking for a ritual that's less about
dying and more about opening the door to
whatever comes next
thank you
[Applause]